hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding hopefully make learning
math a lot less stressful so in this
video we're going to talk about is a
combined rate example okay so what does
it combined rate well let's look at this
example and you'll understand so if John
can shovel the driveway in three hours
and his brother can shovel the driveway
in two hours how long will it take them
working together to shovel the driveway
okay so basically what it is you know
combined rate so we're using them both
the rates together we're trying to find
out how long it takes for them to shovel
the driveway so the way you want to
think about this is like this you want
to think of it as one person's rate
times the time that they spend plus the
other person's rate times the time that
they spend equals in this case one which
is one complete driveway okay so for
John he can his rate is basically one
third of a driveway per hour okay
because it takes him three hours to do
the whole driveway times the amount of
time spent shoveling right okay now his
brother it takes him two hours which
means his rate is half a driveway per
hour okay so half of a driveway times
the number of hours spent okay equals
we're trying to complete one whole
driveway now if they just started to
start a shoveling business and they're
gonna shovel the whole neighborhood you
might want to find out how long it takes
for them to shovel for driveways or five
driveways or six driveways working
together but here we're just trying to
figure out how long it takes them to
shovel the one driveway and so this is
how you would set up the problem now
sometimes when you see it in your
textbook you might see it slightly
differently like they might have this as
like T over three okay plus T over two
or might even be x over three plus X
over two equals one but I just wanted to
kind of show you like this so it kind of
makes a little bit more sense to you
like you probably learned the formula
distance equals rate times time it's
very similar to that it's the rate times
the time so that's why I split it up
like this but of course T is like T over
1 so you can combine those into one
fraction okay now what we're going to do
is we're going to clear
denominators and what you want to do is
you want to multiply everything by the
common denominator so what's the
smallest thing that three two and one
all go into well that's six right so
what we're going to do is going to
multiply the entire equation by six so
we're going to distribute the 6 to the
each of the terms okay in the equation
we're doing it to both sides left and
right so it's keeping the equation
balanced so when you distribute it to
hear you're getting 60 ok divided by
three plus 60 divided by two equals six
over one but you can see the six divided
by three that's reducing or cancelling
down to two t-this is reducing you're
cancelling down to 3t and this is just
six so that's why they call it clearing
the denominators you're eliminating the
denominators so now if we combine like
terms we get five T equals six we divide
by five and you can see the time is
going to be one in one fifth of an hour
okay now if you want to convert that
into minutes 1/5 of an hour is 12
minutes right because 12 times 5 is 60
so well there you go so that's how you
do a combined rate problem just think of
it as splitting the rate in the time you
know separately and then go ahead and
add the two together to get the total
and you could have three people four
people and so on so I hope you're
enjoying the video subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
and I look forward to seeing a future
video I'll talk to you soon